salut aujourd'hui on est le 1er avril
c'est une date très spéciale parce que
ça signifie que ça fait trois mois tout
pile que je fais des vidéos et que vous
en avez une par jour depuis le 1er
janvier au départ mon défi c'est de
faire une vidéo par jour pendant un an
j'ai rempli un quart du défi le 1er
avril c'est surtout le jour du poisson
d'avril c'est le jour de la blague
aujourd'hui je devais mentaliser
quelqu'un et je me suis ravisé je vais
vous donner les six clés pour réussir un
bon poisson d'avril même si vous voyez
cette vidéo à 17h il n'est jamais trop
tard pour faire un poisson d'avril
techniquement avec le fuseau horaire
vous pouvez encore faire votre poisson
d'avril demain en prétextant que dans
certains pays les 12 heures de moins
qu'en france la première astuce et qu'un
poisson d'avril ça se prépare ça se
scénarise un petit peu à l'avant sans
imaginer votre idée écrivait la sur un
bout de papier un poisson d'avril c'est
pas juste te dire tu es moche poisson
d'avril où tu ressembles à sylvain du
rift poisson d'avril
vous pouvez projeter votre scénarisation
comme un mentaliste pour réussir sa la
deuxième astuces qui est plus important
encore le poisson d'avril dans l'idéal
vous ne l'annoncé pas vous même si par
exemple vous voulez créer une situation
comme quoi vous avez gagné un truc
complètement ouf ou que vous avez eu un
job de ouf
plutôt que de l'annoncer vous pouvez
créer un faux message sur votre
répondeur par quelqu'un de vous mettez
dans la combine et ce message répondeur
vous le l'écouterai en haut-parleur
devant la personne à piéger la personne
que vous piéger elle doit elle doit
prendre connaissance de ce poisson là
mais d'une manière indirecte la
troisième astuces à les relier à ça vous
allez faire ce qu'on appelle des
combines soeur ce sont des indices qui
vont credibiliser tout votre poisson
imaginons je veux faire croire à
quelqu'un de chance ouais ça peut
arriver ouais ouais on sépare je
pourrais laisser traîner des tests de
grossesse avec un trait comme s'il avait
fonctionné ferait semblant tout au long
de la journée d'avoir des nausées des
envies des envies de fraises tout le
temps de temps en temps je mettrais ma
main sur mon rang que touchera mon vente
l'air perdu dans mes pensées pour que
tout soit cohérent et pour vraiment
ferrer l'hameçon au final j'ouvrirai une
lettre que j'aurais fait moi même sous
photoshop devant la personne pour
regarder les résultats de la prise de
sang qui dirait que je suis enceinte
et là c'est plus un poisson c'est une
baleine d'avril en même temps si j'étais
enceinte ça voudrait dire que je suis un
hippocampe donc moins n'y croirais pas
trop ça m'emmène quand même à ma
quatrième astuces que plus c'est énorme
plus on y croit si demain je vous faire
croire que je vais jouer à l'olympia
c'est possible c'est cohérent si je la
lance aujourd'hui en tout cas alors que
si je sors du domaine de ma réalité un
mois pour créer mon poisson d'avril là
ce sera beaucoup de plus crédible crédit
parce qu'un possible il faut aller au
delà de la farce
et au-delà et donc 5e astuces qui
rejoint un petit peu la deuxième vous ne
devez pas donner l'impression que vous
cherchez à convaincre si quelqu'un remet
en question ce que vous êtes en train de
vivre et non pas d'annoncé vous le vivez
c'est un fait il ya une accusation comme
quoi c'est une blague vous relevez pas
au bout des doigts oui j'aimerais bien
que ce soit une blague il parlait plus
des conséquences de votre poisson plutôt
que d'essayer de justifier qu'ils
existent et enfin la sixième astuces
penser à l'avancé au désamorçage soit
désamorçage il doit être grand il doit
être somptueux il doit être grandiose
il doit être à la même puissance que
l'été votre poisson imaginons votre
poisson c'est d'avoir gagné un truc de
ouf
un accessoire de chaque équipement de la
gamme apple la finalité de tout ça de
toute cette journée vous devez aller 1-3
rôle et pour aller chercher le colis par
exemple vous y allez vous revenez avec
un gros carton un gros colis et la
personne piégée quand elle ouvrira le
carton elle découvrira dedans peut-être
une boîte de poisson pané ou de hip hop
sont pas nés ça aussi ça doit être une
surprise parce que c'est là où vous
allez profiter du moment c'est la
révélation n'y a pas plus beau que la
révélation d'un poisson d'avril mais ce
qui est un rapport entre ces six astuces
et le mentalisme
oui je pense qu'il ya un vrai rapport
vous devez penser comme l'autre personne
penserait pour pouvoir tout anticipé
vous devez analyser la manière de
réfléchir de la personne que vous les
piéger et devenir elle dans votre tête
et en faisant ça vous allez faire un
poisson c'est une fricassée merci d'être
là toujours de plus en plus nombreux ça
me fait extrêmement plaisir si cette
vidéo vous a plu le fait pas du stop
mais mettez un pouce en l'air continue
aussi à vous abonner en cliquant sur le
petit logo qui a en eau de main je fais
un live pour avoir passé le nouveau
palier je vous avais promis en fait on
se fait le live des mantallot c'est un
apéro live où chacun peut avoir sa
menthe à l'eau ce sera 16 heures tout
pile et surfer risque pourquoi périscope
parce que j'ai pas encore trouvé tout le
fonctionnement des live sur youtube et
je veux pas reporter la date du lay
portez vous bien et rendez vous demain à
11 heures pour le prochain mentale vlog
ciao